tu portables les masses panthères les
mégots pantin les mcdo par terre les
canettes les bouteilles les deux bancs
de l'école pour les enfants
si vous voyez quelqu'un qui jette pas
dans les défenses c'est fini la planète
a besoin de nous merci beaucoup passer
une bonne journée
[Musique]
non
je
moi
[Musique]
le
je sais quoi
cédric le sommet marseillais masse of
english l'escargot anglais
[Musique]
on est allé dans les écoles au début de
la marche
ai je demandé aux enfants avez vous déjà
vu quelqu'un jeté par terre de 90 élèves
tous
oui qui si la maman une fois d'accord
[Musique]
mais pour la pastèque par l'oenologue
on sait qu'il faut pas jeter et c'est
toujours aussi peu oui donc si chacun
ramasse une chose un déchet n'importe
quoi par jour
ce sera dans un endroit plus clean et si
on veut être heureux dans un bel
environnement
[Musique]